on parle avec notre ca ce soir jean luc
jean martin bonsoir bonsoir
alors chars les mots qui dit que c'est
valérie plantes qui responsable du
revirement sur le règne de l'est qu'elle
était ravie du projet c'est le mot qu'il
employa peine quelques semaines et que
là avec dix jours seulement il ya dix
jours elle n'en voulait plus jean-luc
d'abord est ce que vous achetez cette
explication que la mairesse de montréal
finalement à torpiller le projet
non non pas du tout monsieur legault le
dit il n'y avait pas de l'acceptation
sociale et par conséquent plus habitué
aux élections sans lien alors j'ai
choisi ces batailles et sir terry et je
suis bien content à jean martin j'aime
bien l'analyse politique de change lui
que je pense que beaucoup de ceux là
dedans mais je me suis retourné un
communiqué de presse de janvier 2015
vous savez qu'on a annoncé cette
collaboration la caisse les
infrastructures et gouvernement essaie
disait là dedans qu'il fallait que la
caisse parce que les projets en accord
avec toutes les parties prenantes oui
évidemment quand on parle d'un projet de
transport à montréal montréal est une
partie prenante donc si la ville était
opposée c'est naturel que le projet ait
pas de l'avant mais on comprend bien
quand même messieurs que c'est le
gouvernement du québec qui décident
parce que si pendant des pendants des
mois la mairesse a exprimé certaines
inquiétudes ou
exprimer
certaines oppositions disons pile
gouvernement continuait à aller là
dedans ça veut dire que ces
gouvernements spa la mairesse qui décide
que le projet va pas de l'avant c'est le
gouvernement du québec qui décide
d'accepter que le projet n'aille pas de
l'avant êtes vous d'accord avec ce que
je dis aujourd'hui à huy actuellement
c'est lui qui paie oui et dans le cadre
de son deal c'est que monsieur leubou là
il ya une pollution au cip le troisième
ligne est repris mais le tramway etc il
faut que je choisisse un peu ce matin il
a pas que décidé d'en laisser tomber
et heureusement pour nous c'est 10
milliards maltais passé alors tant mieux
au moins on se débarrasse de
moi mais le projet pas mort pour autant
il va en avoir un il s'appellera
peut-être à l'om de l'est comme on dit
aujourd'hui charles est mort mais il va
quand même y avoir un projet et
jean-martin
safran projets dans les laveries il faut
qu'ils aient un projet qui relie les la
ville à tous qui l'entourent dans les
classes centre-ville de montréal parce
que cette région là on le dit souvent
l'émission ici c'est a rendu des
services industriels l'immense au québec
mais même au canada puis ces dernières
décennies s'était un peu délaissé puis
c'est une région qui est vraiment un peu
isolée du reste d'ailleurs les taux d'à
peu près tout ce qui est mesures
sociales ou de santé sont plus bas dans
l'est de l'île que dans l'ouest il faut
vraiment revitaliser cette région là
avec le potentiel que l'incroyable donc
il faut qu'ils aient un autre projet qui
s'appellera pas le ray mais qui serait
pas sous cette forme là mais il faut les
relier mais je ramène quand même les
propos de charles et manquant charlem on
parle de ce lob il dit nouveau projet il
y avait un nouveau projet et j'ai appris
du gouvernement du québec que la
mairesse avait appelé pour dire qu'elle
voulait un autre projet c'est quand même
fondamental jean-martin de l'utilisation
des mots est ce que la caisse
s'est débarrassé de ce projet là qu'ils
étaient trop complexes
je sais pas j'étais pas dans les
discussions mais quand on dit qu'on veut
pas d'un trajet donné peut-être que pour
monsieur heymans et un nouveau projet
mais j'étais pas dans l'éduction que pas
vraiment commenter si c'était vraiment
ce qui a été dit mais chose certaine le
tracé du centre-ville de montréal
n'étaient pas acceptées par tout le
monde mais si vous étiez un petit ainsi
qu un oiseau qui se promenaient par là
vous auriez entendu coiffe passé mais je
pense que la caisse une fusée de
rentabilité là dedans aussi donc
peut-être qu'un projet beaucoup plus
cher pour desservir la même région
l'intéressé - ce qui est pas plus mal
non plus le projet va se faire il faut
qu'ils se fassent puis si c'est pas le
cas ce sera notre promoteur jean luc
là-dessus
mais je pense que ce qu'il autrui
principalement là c'est là entre et de
soulever des vagues tout le monde est
accompli oui il n'y avait pas grand
chose à la 25e par en dessous ben projet
même si la caisse 0,7 à cause des
édifices et externe mais quelle son coup
au crible alors par conséquent on était
rendu avec un projet trop qui kidnappent
à la rentabilité
à la cat ça prend beaucoup de monde pour
payer un projet aussi dispendieux et
l'homme le mieux c'est de l'abandonner
je demande si je suis peut-être que
monsieur bien conduit dix d'abandonner
çà et francon chèque de 100 millions et
à d'autres je vais y revenir aux 100
millions mais ce que vous pensez gens de
le modèle de gouvernance qui parce que
dans le fond la caisse de dépôt veut des
projets rentables pour lui ramener le
maximum de rendement est ce que c'est à
la caisse de faire des projets de
transports collectifs dans l'intérêt
public et des besoins des populations
jean-luc d'abord bien sûr que non la
caisse le dit elle-même ses petits pas
dans notre mandat très belle le départ
le rem premier le premier 1 mais
peut-être leur m de longueur mais elle
répondu à une demande du gouvernement
faites nous un projet qui rend pas pour
vous il a accepté le deuxième projet on
est c'est la même chose en essayant de
passer
à travers toutes les instances
s'aperçoit que là ça marche pas il faut
que le gouvernement et les instances la
ville créera un projet et ensuite à
laquelle soit un autre construisez leur
dans cet ordre là des choses le
gouvernement
jean martin doit-il demandé à la caisse
de développer des projets où le
gouvernement doit-il faire un projet et
demander ensuite à la caisse hissel
l'intéressent mais moi je moi je veux un
très bon oeil le fait que si un projet
l'acceptabilité sociale et que c'est
rentable que ce soit la caisse qu'il
fasse plutôt qu'un promoteur souvent
étrangers moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça dans ce que six ans que
les parties prenantes j'aime pas
l'expression l'homme et les parties
impliquées on n'aimait pas tout le
projet et la caisse vous y voyez la
rentabilité réduite d'un autre projet
que celui qui voulait faire qui était
plus simple donc c'est peut-être
économiquement très concevable que la
caisse devait se retirer de ça nous
coûte 100 millions quand même à ce qui
se passe présentement il faut rembourser
100 millions jean martin est ce que
c'est acceptable ben il fallait y penser
avant si c'est dans le contrat à
contrôler un contrôle le moindre mal
c'est qu'au moins c'est la caisse de
dépôt qui reçoit 100 millions qui est
une institution paragouvernemental ou
publiques au québec donc ça ne va pas au
moins encore une fois chez une compagnie
privée étrangère ça reste dans le bas de
laine des québécois ce n'est plus ça
fait sursauter de voir ça mais au moins
ça reste chez nous jean-luc merci des
dépenses premièrement les 100 millions
ses impressions d'un projet total de 10
milliards et c'est clair qu'il ya eu des
dépenses la caisse par la portable et à
travers dans ce projet alors c'est
normal comme on ne rembourse si on
décide d'abandonner
est ce que c'est un échec je laisse
d'abord charles vraiment charles est mon
pour répondre à cette question nous pas
un échec parce qu'on est allé on a
répondu à la question dans un temps
rapide dans des circonstances pour
toujours facile on l'a défendu et je
trouve c'est un travail qui était de
classe mondiale la caisse n'a pas de
visée
de tapisser le québec de tous les rêves
mais du plus de raismes possible on le
fait parce qu'on a un coeur aussi
développement économique du québec tient
demain portant ces infrastructures nous
en termes de qualité de vie en termes
d'accessibilité une fois davantage
vos commentaires jean-luc sur les propos
de chargement est super contents de
l'entente de pâtes apicil québec du même
projet surtout que ces projets là c'est
des projets des années 60 sont des gros
traits beaucoup de béton ont un fil
électrique par dessus on est rendus
maintenant qu'on a des véhicules à
batterie etc sont beaucoup plus
écologique et qui perdit beaucoup plus
flexible outils pour transporter les
gens genre tel bain à l'origine du rem
vous savez en compagnie tra l'an 2018
avait plein de projets qui avaient été
mis de l'avant
pas seulement le real y en avait des
moins chères qui avait plus de
connectivité donc je pense que si on
fait un tronçon du rem qui est quand
même à la fine pointe de ce qu'il sera
dans son domaine c'est correct mais on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir drm partout il
ya d'autres modes de transport dans
l'économie ce n'est quelques années mais
beaucoup d'autres dernier point sur la
rémunération de monsieur m en 6 millions
300 mille au total la rémunération
globale pour 2021 québec solidaire a
posé beaucoup de questions acharnement
là dessus voici un extrait vous n'êtes
pas gêné d'avoir un salaire si élevé
je pense que vous me posez des questions
par rapport à 6 je considère que le
ministre est moins talentueux tout les
gens travaillent pas fort ou maintenir
sur un terrain je pense qu'ils aient pas
du tout représentatif de comment je
pense ou j'aperçois
le fonctionnement de la société vous
porter des jugements de valeur sur
commun je porte une opinion sur tout
l'écosystème lancé paul cox quelqu'un de
respectueux
j'ai quelqu'un de responsable
ok donc c'est un peu tordu disons le
comme ça c'est le dernier point c'est la
dernière question que je pose à chacun
jean-martin d'abord est-ce que c'est
justifié 6 million trois cent mille pour
le pdg de la caisse moi je pense que
deux questions une question relative à
une question absolue la question
relative c'est pas ces pauvres dans le
monde un fonds de 400 mille 400
milliards dont le grand patron est payé
6 millions ou plus même donc en relatif
c'est pas très rares les questions
absolue c est ce que c'est normal qu'un
grand patron dans quelques secteurs que
ce soit face 50 100 200 fois le salaire
d'un employé moyen dans l'entreprise
soit je pense que dans les contrats
sociaux futurs dans les sociétés qu'on a
il va y avoir des limites à la
rémunération j'en suis convaincu
aujourd'hui on n'a pas trouvé la
solution à ce problème ce qui arrive
c'est que les entreprises anyama un
dirigeant d'entreprise c'est toute la
différence un bon dirigeant transformer
l'entreprise est un mauvais équilibre
alors c'est important maintenant les
conseils d'administration qui fixe ces
rémunérations la faune des enquêtes avec
les autres pilotes problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas trouvé la solution à ça et
suivent les uns les autres alors à
mesure qu'ils n'auraient qui a demandé
l'autre essaie de garder le meilleur ou
h et pense qu'il est capable de garder
le meilleur en alimentant lui aussi et
encore on n'a pas la solution c'est un
bon sujet à rediscuter ensemble parce
que c'est très intéressant c'est assez
fondamentale merci messieurs mardi